foreign
[Music]
there are a million one places we could
start so my understanding is you are a
straight D student till grade 10 if I'm
getting that right and maybe this is a
segue maybe it isn't but
why was the book The stopwatch gang
important to you and could you provide
some context for how that appeared in
your life
so my parents were in the military I
live with my mom my stepfather my
biological father lived somewhere else
and we moved every year so every year I
had a new school I think the first
school that I went to two years in a row
was grade 10 and 11 to put things in
context same school two years in a row
for grade eight
I decided I was going to live with my
biological father
so I moved across the country
live with him and for various reasons
this was
a disaster
uh you know somebody who really didn't
have a lot of experience parenting Me
growing up all of a sudden has a
teenager
my stepmother all of a sudden inheriting
a teenager living in the middle of
nowhere I'm already a borderline
delinquent I almost got kicked out of
school in grade seven for skipping
school like I skipped school for like
seven or eight weeks as you go see a
child psychologist to make sure as a
condition of not being expelled that I
was like there was nothing seriously
wrong with me
and so in grade 8 I just started getting
in more and more trouble I started
hanging around the wrong people like
your your environment sort of determines
your behavior a lot not only your
physical environment but the people you
surround yourself with and you know it's
just the slow escalation and you know if
somebody said hey you're gonna go break
into somebody's house you'd never do it
but if you start with vandalism and you
start staying out late you start like
doing things that you're not supposed to
all of a sudden vandalism or breaking
into a house is like the next logical
step so we're doing this
book report
for grade eight and I go to the library
and I'm like not interested in Reading
I'm not even interested in doing my
schoolwork at all and I just happened to
land in this true crime section at this
Elementary School which is like four
books long and there's one book called
the stopwatch gang and I was like what's
this about I pick it up it's about a
bunch of bank robbers and I was like oh
this is this is awesome like this is my
kind of book why has nobody shown me
that you can like read about this stuff
so I get home and I'm like reading this
book and a few days later my friends
like knock on the door and we all had
like dirt bikes so we're all like you
know living on 20 acres you're commuting
by dirt bike to your front test and
where are you at this point in time this
is in carp Ontario Canada got it okay
just to place it for people yeah so they
knock on the door and they're like come
out with us and
you know let's let's have some fun and I
was like one chapter away from the end
and I don't know you've probably read a
really good book and you want nothing to
like interrupt you in that moment you're
like no like the world doesn't exist I
need to finish this book there's nothing
more important so I like lied because if
I told them I was reading a book that
would go over like a lead balloon but I
was like you know I'm not really feeling
that well tonight I'm gonna stay in I'm
sorry about that and so they go out and
they end up breaking into somebody's
house and getting caught and a whole
bunch of bad things happen as a result
of that and if I was there I probably
would have been doing that with them
but luckily I wasn't there I didn't do
that with them I found out about what
happened and this is a chance event this
wasn't me like thinking about anything
and saying no to this thing it was just
pure 100 luck
but I sort of got a little bit scared
straight after that not in terms of like
I'm gonna devote myself to school work
and like get better grades but straight
in the sense of I don't want to do this
I don't want to get into this trouble
and then from that moment on books sort
of became an outlet for me to live in an
imaginary world and to escape the world
that was actually in and to sort of be
part of something else have you ever had
a book do that to you for you for sure
oh no I literally
yesterday this is not something I should
probably advertise broadly I'm not proud
of it but I was listening to the second
of three books in this Trilogy by Joe
Abercrombie and I had six minutes left
in this very
very good chapter
and my mom had arrived a little bit
early to go to dinner and so I was
banking on having that extra time before
the pickup to finish this chapter and it
was it bothered me so much that I got up
I said I really had to go to the
bathroom and I went to the bathroom and
I just walked around outside the
restaurant for six minutes and finished
this chapter in the audiobook that was
last night so yes I definitely know the
feeling that's awesome right and you're
like how dare you show up early
yeah that's which is not the tone I want
to take with my mom but I was like oh
okay yeah I forgot my my OCD as it
applies to time should not be imposed on
all other people so that's okay took a
little loitering Meander as a bathroom
break at dinner that's okay got it done
and then in grade nine like my grade
nine teacher wrote in my report card
that Shane would be lucky to graduate
from high school
so what happened I mean a couple of
observations number one if you had been
convicted I'm not sure what the legal
equivalent is something like felony or
whatever that was with your friends that
certainly I would imagine would have
complicated later work in government on
some level oh totally or I could have
but what were the inflection points that
led to you being
employable
especially at an intelligence agency in
2001. that is also like a crazy story
because intelligence agencies I mean
they vet people like up down so they
interviewed neighbors they interviewed
teachers they interviewed the references
that I put down they talked to people
that I didn't put down like they want to
know about your life and they want to
know who you are as a person especially
for for students and and for people like
me who have a bit more of a I would say
troubled background right like I don't
I'm not a straight A student I didn't go
to the the best schools in life I didn't
have this clean I had a clean record but
I didn't you know if you look at the the
sort of supporting evidence it's like
well this person's been in trouble over
the course of their life and you know
they talk to my professors and like one
of my professors hated me and so that
conversation was like it was just so
weird like we had this I don't know if
other people had this but in physics
first year physics they had this
computer program that generated your
assignments for you so everybody in the
class literally had this different
assignment and each question was
different there was like 10 versions of
question one and then all the numbers
were different so if you even if you had
the same version of question one that
you know you could find somebody else
with it
you have the same version you would have
different numbers so you couldn't just
copy the answer and so all the kids in
school all the rich kids basically
bought the same tutor and this tutor for
20 bucks or whatever he just like you
gave him your sheet and he spit out the
answers for you because he had all the
10 versions of the question he would
just plug in your numbers and you go to
school and the way to submit your
assignment wasn't you actually submitted
paper this is like the dawn of the
internet like 1998-ish and so you would
submit your assignment almost like over
telnet you you would like log in and it
would say what's your answer to question
one and you would submit your answer and
I was like this takes a lot of time I
gotta work full time I don't know if I
can spend the 20 hours a week it
actually takes to do this but I was in
computer science I was like I'll write a
little program that just sort of like
goes from negative a thousand to
positive a thousand and guesses in
increments of like point one and so I
did this little program and it worked
great I got 20 out of 20 on every
assignment until March of my first year
the teacher comes in and he's one of
those transparencies and I don't know if
people remember transparencies oh yeah
the overhead projectors so it's like a
PowerPoint graph that he puts on this
projector and it's like average guesses
on the y-axis and student number on the
x-axis and like the average number of
guesses per question was I don't know
like 17 or something and mine was like
in the millions
so he's like I want to see the student
after class and I was careful like I had
read all the policies and procedures and
it says unlimited guessing so you're are
submitting like a million guesses via
telnet is that yeah like I'm not doing
anything I just basically so there's no
downside for a number of guesses you're
only rewarded for getting the answer
right in one of those guesses exactly
and so why not yeah I I read all the
policies and procedures right like I was
very careful about reading all the rules
to make sure I wasn't violating any
rules but I would go to bed I would just
basically like hit run on this program
and I would wake up and I would have my
full assignment submitted 20 out of 20.
so so Shane gets retained after class
was it to discipline you and wag a
finger at you or was there something
else that came with the conversation oh
so he was like you're gonna get zero on
all your assignments and I was like what
that's not fair at all
and he's like well we're sort of like
retroactively changing the rules and I
was like that doesn't make any sense
that's not fair like I followed all like
I can't all the rich kids are like
hiring tutors I can't do that like it
doesn't make sense just go with my exam
Mark as my mark you know sort of thing
and he said no and and basically the
assignments were so heavily weighted
that I ended up failing physics because
of this it was so crazy and so
when I'm getting my job they actually
talk to this teacher now how did you
come in touch with I understand why he
would have an ax to grind or at least it
sounds like the kind of guy who would
have maybe something scornful and
spiteful to say how did you even get
connected with an intelligence agency
were they recruiting in certain centers
nearby do they canvass the whole country
I don't know how it works it's just sort
of luck right I was doing computer
science at a time when you know the rise
of the internet I didn't want to work
for like Nortel or any of these big
companies I really wanted to work for an
intelligence agency I thought that would
be really fun and coincidence that they
happened to be at my school I like
problems that are not really solvable
right that are intractable that are big
and gnarly and that you can sort of like
you can never quite solve but you can
get better at and I had this my parents
were in the military so I had a
patriotic sense of giving back to my
country like how fortunate am I to be
born into a country with freedom and
good school system and a good health
care system and I was taught and brought
up in a way that you have an obligation
to give back and for anybody that knows
me I mean I'm not going to give back
standing on the front lines of the
machine gun that's like just dangerous
for everybody involved but if I could
use my brain in a way that was giving
back to the the people and the community
and the country in which I grew up I
thought that that was a really good sort
of win-win interesting problems giving
back at the same time they came to the
school I applied for a job and if I
didn't get it I was basically going to
go back and do my MBA right away and do
something else but I ended up getting it
ended up working with an incredible
group of talented people starting what
then went on to become the largest part
of the intelligence agency I think now
or the most valuable part of it and for
people in the U.S what would that agency
be comparable to if you can say would it
be comparable to the NSA comparable to
CIA comparable to other three-letter
acronym that would be the NSA got it
I'm gonna take a heart left here to ask
you about maybe since you like
intractable problems to ask you about
one that I know a lot of my friends are
contending with which is thinking about
how moving around helps or handicaps
their kids you moved around a ton you
have kids
how do you think that experience of
moving from place to place school to
school affected you positively and
negatively or in the pro and con columns
so to speak and how how do you think
about that or how would you suggest
other people think about that if they
currently have very mobile lives and are
wondering how that will affect their
kids
there's a couple different ways to think
about that as it relates to my
experience which is
I knew I was moving so I knew at the end
of the year I was going to be in a
different School
I mean that became apparent sort of at
least by grade six or seven and so every
year I could experiment with myself and
not consciously but I could emphasize
different parts of myself just do I fit
in with the jocks do I fit in with the
nerds do it like what is my group of
people and you know I could play a role
for a year and I knew the the downside
is I knew that I was moving in a year
and so I knew all of these relationships
were sort of transitory so I think the
biggest impact it had on me is even in
adulthood
it took me a long time to sort of like
develop
this person's gonna be in my life for a
long period of time this isn't like a
transitory relationship and transitory
means
you know it's just gonna go and so you
don't invest in it you don't invest in
it the same way that you would invest in
your best friend or somebody like that
because you knew that closer you got to
that person at the end of the year the
harder it would be to leave and so at
that point in time it was really
difficult for me coming out of that
becoming a university student and then
joining the workforce
to not have this mental default of this
is going to go away or I might not see
this person but in in flip side it's
like I'm going to work with this person
for the next 15 years and I think that
was really hard for me to sort of like
catch on to it took a few years for me
to to really start investing in those
friendships and those relationships and
the way that I wanted to
if you were sitting at a dinner table
with some let's let's say the relatively
new parents they have kids under the age
of two right so the kids aren't going to
school for a little bit but it's not the
distant future and they have a life
where they spend X number of months in
one place and why number of months and
in another and maybe they're thinking
about living in a different state or a
different country but they don't want to
screw their kids up yeah maybe indulging
those Explorations at the same time
they're not sure if they want to be in
one place in a fixed way
what would you say to those people
my advice for what it's worth is I don't
think it really matters much until
they're sort of like grade seven and
eight
and certainly in high school it matters
a lot in high school the consistency the
friend group the sort of
knowing what to expect because they're
if I map myself to just my kids in their
age like there's a lot of uncertainty in
their life there's a lot of things going
on that we don't see and then adding on
to that sort of like you're going to be
in a different school with a different
system with the different teachers with
you can't really
thrive in that environment easily that
doesn't mean you can't Thrive it just
means you're making it harder than it
has to be
but before that I would say up until
grade six again just going on my
experience with my kids what they're
really learning in school and from
friendships is like how do we be social
how do we interact with other people how
do we get in the habit of going to
school how do we learn to read and learn
to do basic math and that you can sort
of get anywhere in the world really
really easily grade seven at least for
my kids is when it started to change and
that's in part because of the schools
that I sent them to
but I think it I think it starts to
matter in grade seven increasingly and
definitely in high school what type of
schools did you send them to
I'm a big believer that kids should be
challenged and I don't I don't think
that the
the schools around my house challenge
the kids so I found a school in Ottawa
that I had to drive to and drop off my
kids and I'm the type of parent that's
like you can do this
you can do things you don't believe
you're capable of and so starting at
grade seven my kids were getting 90
minutes of homework a night they were
taking School in a different language
and they were pushed and challenged and
the standards of this school and I take
a lot of flock for this even from
friends of mine but the standards of the
school are unrelenting
they don't care how you feel
and that you know is very
counter-cultural in today's message but
if you go in there and you haven't done
your homework it does not matter you get
a zero and to put things in context we
went to my grandmother's funeral in May
and they were one day late getting their
essay in and they were one day late they
got 10 off their essay because they were
one day late and the school's approach
to this is like look we want to produce
effective adults
and that means you're gonna fail in
grade seven you're not going to fail
academically because everybody there is
really smart you're gonna fail at these
little life things that you should have
taken that into account when you planned
your essay submission you should and
they put it on the students and they do
it in such a way that the kids at first
like
my son was crying like every night
because he is naturally really really
smart and he goes to the school and it's
in a different language and now it's 90
minutes of work a night is it French
what is the like yeah so it's French and
so it's I don't speak French like I
didn't speak French to him at home he
hasn't spoken French for in like two and
a half years because of covid basically
and all of a sudden he's thrust into a
French School
and they're unrelenting so
he was so naturally Spar that he didn't
have to work for anything and that
school eliminates that they're like no
you have to work and if you don't work
you can't get good grades and it was so
hard on him and like I'm the parent he's
like hey I love you I know this is
really hard I know you can do it let's
shift our mindset around this and by the
end of the I would say December he was
like loving it he's loved being
challenged and you know when it came
time to pick a high school he literally
his filter was what school is going to
challenge me the most and I was like
that school did an awesome job I'm so
happy that that's the way he's thinking
about this because it's not about grades
I mean I would rather him basically fail
at doing something hard than really
succeed at doing something easy because
I feel like we're so we we get wrapped
up as parents
our kids successes our success and so
their grades become our success but
really what we want to do is produce
independent adults who are capable of
handling the ups and downs of life and
that means that they're going to fail
they're going to struggle they're going
to have teachers they don't like they're
going to get grades that you know maybe
they do or don't deserve
and so I think about all of these things
I'm a I would say an example of
a similar experience in the sense that I
went to a very easy
reasonably
disorganized set of schools up until the
end of my freshman year in high school
and then
was transferred and this was my idea but
I transferred to a very difficult school
for me at least in New Hampshire a
boarding school and I got absolutely
crushed it was schooling six days a week
mandatory Sports every semester
you had classes also
six period I think it was after Sports
and then you would have seeded meals
with code and tie and so on several
times a week and the whole nine and it
was so challenging I went from being
easily top of the pack to maybe bottom
of the middle of the pack maybe lower
right I was suddenly
undistinguished from any intellectual
perspective and kids who were at this
school St Paul's knew how to work too A
lot of them and I'm so grateful for it
because they were incredibly
tough
discipline was demanded and everything
after that was relatively easy even
Princeton and and so on I mean the the
workload was no problem and I think in
retrospect that it was really critical
to my formation that's also where I was
introduced to Japanese and other
languages and had my exchange experience
which changed everything for me but
being taught early that the world will
not conform to all of your unique needs
and preferences is like you said it's
very counter-cultural I don't think if
you train a child to expect this is true
for
train anyone to expect that they are
going to drive decisions what they want
is always going to be taken into account
what they like is always going to be at
the top of other priority lists it's
setting them up for a lifetime of
disappointment and disorder and
depression probably all at once anyway
this is maybe a strong response but I
agree with the approach pause for once I
want to know you said this was your
decision what made you decide that where
did that come from
I guess it was informed by a couple of
other inputs so one was a I was very
lucky I mean luck plays into all of this
so much
fret one friend of mine had escaped Long
Island and he had gone to Saint Paul's
and he came back and he basically said
you gotta get out of here you have to
escape and
it happened that around the same time I
think it was a math teacher and one
other teacher effectively said the same
thing they're like Tim I can't go any
faster but you're not going to get what
you need here
and there wasn't really a strong
suggestion as to a solution in that case
but those things all combined
to peaking my curiosity about these
things called boarding school I didn't
know what boarding schools were really
outside of a few stories from my
friend's experience so I went to the
local library back when you had to do
this and took out these really thick
guides to boarding schools tried to
figure things out
and ultimately got
a few scholarships and then my whole
extended family helped pay for this
thing because it's expensive and my
family didn't have my immediate family
didn't have very much money so I was
very lucky that my grandparents and
other people also chipped in to make it
happen
and I think that fundamentally I had
also been competing in sports and I
recognized in sports like if you're not
losing
routinely you're not training with the
right people
does that make sense at least in
wrestling it's like if if you were to
train on a tennis team and your goal was
to become
the best tennis player possible if you
were just annihilating everyone on your
team you're kind of on the wrong team if
your goal is to compete in larger and
larger Arenas so I
I appreciated that and enjoyed that
with respect to competition I was very
competitive but I couldn't
really apply that to the academics in
any meaningful way until I went to St
Paul's and then I got my ass kicked but
it was it was the The Beneficial
adaptive ass kicking that I think I
really needed so
I'm all for it I think we we missed that
right like school has become
almost too easy we're not challenging
the kids and we're not holding them to a
high enough standard and it's causing
all these Downstream problems later on
in life
at least that's my view and I want my
kids to be chilling I want them to fail
I want them to learn how to overcome
these obstacles and you must have gone
through something similar right when
you're going from sort of like lead dog
to you know maybe bottom middle of the
pack like where's my identity you're not
just dealing with how do I develop the
systems to study and get the work done
and all these people already know it so
I'm behind but you're dealing with all
these identity crisis in terms of your
ego and how you think about yourself
oh totally it was for the first six
months I mean I was I just I felt like I
was always behind I was always behind I
was always having to choose what I
wouldn't finish because I just was not
fast enough I was not organized enough I
did not have the time management skills
and figuring out when I could take a
20-minute nap so that I could then stay
up an extra you know hour and a half
after dinner to finish a b and c and
then
managed to do this other thing in
preparations that I'd be well prepared
for athletic practice the next day after
a full day of coursework after Chapel
every morning just about I think it was
six days a week we had Chapel it's
either five or six days which is mostly
roll call of sorts and announcements but
there are also hymns and this and the
other thing it was a very very full
schedule
and I'm I'm grateful for that and people
listening have probably heard the
expression if you want something done
give it to a busy man I mean it could be
a woman of course but the idea being if
someone is busy and they have a full
schedule they learn how to juggle that
full schedule and if you have an
incomplete schedule I think especially
in those formative years in high school
you you do not by necessity develop the
time management skills that if you
really want to charge hard later in life
you are going to need and
feel lucky very very lucky I mean if I
hadn't had that friend who was the proof
of concept
who knows who knows where I would be you
know it's it's uh so so let's let's come
back to to your life story what was
68131 I think it was dot blogger.com if
I'm getting that right
what was that
so when I was working at the
intelligence agency everybody I started
two weeks before September 11th
literally two weeks later the world
changed
and everybody was thrust into roles and
responsibilities over the coming sort of
like decade basically that they weren't
ready for
nobody could have prepared you for you
just had to sort of do your best
and I remember being put in charge of
something that I didn't feel like I
could
quite handle and I'm making decisions
that sort of impact myself and impact my
team and impact my country and impact
troops in theater and you know I have no
idea what I'm doing
and so I
went to my boss one day after a
particularly challenging operation I
said you know here's how I thought about
it I don't think I'm ready for this job
like I I don't think I can do this and
he basically just looked at me and he
was like you're all we got like
what else are we gonna do like we're all
just doing the best we can get back to
work and I was like that's the worst pep
talk I have ever heard in my life
so I was like well I think people
deserve better than me and what can I do
if I can't sort of like get out of this
role I was like so I started following
people around in the organization I was
like how do these people make decisions
what can I learn from them and I went
back and sort of did an MBA and when I
was doing my MBA I just you know
rediscovered Charlie Munger and Warren
Buffett and part of my MBA it was so
useless and I don't mean that in a
negative way it just wasn't giving me
what I needed at that particular moment
to get better at the things that I
wanted to get better at
but Charlie Munger and Warren Buffett
were and so I created this website which
was
68131-1440.blogger.com which I don't own
today somebody else is like taking this
over probably because I talk about it a
lot
but the website was basically the zip
code for Berkshire Hathaway Dash the
unit number of Berkshire Hathaway and
Hewitt Plaza and it was my online
Journal
now keep in mind this is like I don't
know what year it is but I'm not allowed
to have a LinkedIn profile I'm not
allowed to have any social you Google me
I do not exist the intelligence agency
would be livid if you had any sort of
public profile any sort of anything at
all and here I am I'm like oh I'm just
going to create this online journal and
this is how I'm going to Chronicle my
Learning and Development right like I'm
just gonna take notes and I'm going to
connect these ideas and I'm going to
synthesize them and I'm going to
compress them
and that is the act of reflection so I'm
gonna basically learn things on my own
I'm going to reflect on them and then
I'm going to write about them
and so I started this website and then
eventually I don't even know how at this
point
we got to I think it was like 25 000
readers or something and then all of a
sudden I started getting these emails
which is like I hate typing in the name
of your website like you knew can you
basically like change the name and I was
like fine I'll just call it Farnam
Street right which was the homage to
Buffett and Monger who I know have
played like such a critical role in your
life too yeah yeah they have I mean I
remember somebody I can't recall who it
was but dug up the video
of my
wavering voice at the Berkshire hath Ray
shareholder meeting when I asked my
question from the mic from the nosebleed
seats I have been informed by them for
sure I mean I have incredible respect
for both of them were you introduced to
them by Buffett the making of an
American capitalist or how did you get
introduced to them so I read buff at the
making of an American capitalist I think
in University but sort of like
everything got put on the back burner
once I joined the intelligence agency
and like the world changed right
September 11th changed everything I
didn't really come up I mean I worked
six days a week 12 hours a day for years
didn't really have a lot of occasions
didn't have a lot of long weekends and
everybody else was doing the exact same
thing right and it was the best time of
my life if that makes sense too not only
you're working incredibly hard you're
working on Amazing problems that you're
really attracted to and you're working
with a group of highly intelligent
dedicated people like it doesn't really
get much better than that from a quality
of life point of view but everything
sort of like all these outside interests
get put on hold I mean I'm coming home
I'm like sort of like spending a little
bit of time with
the woman who is my girlfriend at the
time and then I'm going to bed and I'm
waking up and like just repeating on
rents and then the NBA was sort of a way
for me to step back from that for a
couple years
do a less intensive role there while
doing a full-time MBA and that was when
I got reconnected I was like oh yeah
there's this Warren Buffett guy and
Charlie Munger but what are they doing
they're making decisions in the real
world and they seem really good at it so
what can I learn from them
so when you had the somewhat
awkward numerical string right when you
had the ZIP code as the URL what were
some of the if you remember were there
any particular pieces that struck a
chord with folks because that's those
are non-trivial numbers you're talking
about in terms of readership were there
any particular threads or pieces
that come to mind that really struck a
chord in the early days
I have to go back to be sure but I I
think there's stuff about like I was
trying to figure out how Daniel conman
came up with cognitive biases and Warren
Buffett and Charlie Munger didn't really
talk about cognitive biases but seemed
to avoid them and so I spent a lot of
time trying to like reconcile
how cognitive biases can help you in the
real world and so what I sort of hit on
at least from my point of view is like
cognitive biases are really good at
explaining why you made a mistake in the
past but the really poor preventing you
from making mistakes in the future so
they're they're intellectually very
satisfying but they don't really prevent
you
like if you create a checklist of
cognitive biases and you're a smart
person you're just basically going to
outsmart yourself right am I
overconfident no I'm not overconfident
right like I got this I did the work and
and so the story you tell yourself you
sort of like talk yourself out of them
in a lot of ways
which is a bit of an irony to them but
tell me more about that what do you mean
by talking yourself out of them well you
come up with a checklist like a lot of
people have tried this they come up with
a checklist of cognitive biases and
they're like okay I'm gonna see if this
applies to me so sunk cost fallacy this
that and the other thing expectancy bias
or whatever it might be
just putting it putting together a list
of things that one is intending to avoid
is that right yes yeah yeah and then but
consider sunk costs right so you make a
decision and then you pull out your
checklist and you're like well am I
making this because you know am I
considering sunk cost or am I just
making this fresh and you've already
decided at this moment right so you're
just justifying and rationalizing the
decision you're saying so you right you
tell yourself a story about why sunk
cost doesn't apply in this situation or
why you're not overconfident in this
situation right use confirmation bias to
address your other biases exactly right
and the smarter you are the the better
the stories get and the more believable
they get
I'd love to get your help defining a
phrase just I suppose explaining a
phrase and then segueing into a
conversation around mental models and
cognitive biases and so on so ordinary
moments determine your position and your
position determines your results so what
what is meant by that line and what is
meant by position
so the counter-intuitive Insight that I
had about decision making from studying
sort of Buffett Munger and Peter Kaufman
and a host of other people who who've
influenced my thinking
is that they almost never find
themselves out of position
and if you want to think of it as
position as your circumstances they're
never forced by circumstances into doing
something that they don't want to do and
often that means they look like an idiot
in the short term but in the long term
they win if you consider Buffett for
example we've talked about you know he
closes down his partnership
during a bull market in the 60s
because he doesn't know how to invest
anymore he's lost touch you can't find
what what worked for him he reopens it
later in terms of Berkshire Hathaway
Time Magazine I think it was 1999 he's
on the cover as being out of touch
2001 stock market bursts
right now today I think as of last
quarter he's got 150 billion dollars on
the balance sheet and so what he's
always doing is he he's everybody thinks
he's out of touch and he looks like an
idiot but he always wins because no
matter what the outcome is he wins if
the stock market goes up he wins if the
stock market crashes he wins because
he's put himself in a position where no
matter what happens he can take
advantage of circumstances rather than
having circumstances take advantage of
him and I think that that's a key
element we don't realize if you put
Warren Buffett in a bad position
where all of his options are bad it
doesn't matter how smart he is it
doesn't matter how Warren Buffett he is
everybody looks like an idiot when
they're in a bad position and everybody
looks like a genius when they're in a
good position do you then create that
position by having a handful of
Commandments and I'm making these up I'm
not saying this is what Buffett does
because I haven't tracked him as closely
as you have but for instance I know
someone who's of a similar cut from a
similar cloth and he's like no short
positions no leverage that that and he
has four or five rules that he follows
which means he doesn't always beat the S
P 500 let's say but he's very rarely in
a position where he has to
where he's a distressed seller
or is forced into a bad position right
so he's able to play a very long game so
I guess my please keep going but I'm
wondering
how you
consistently create
that type of position
so let me talk about it in terms of
finance and then apply it to something
else that's totally you would think it
doesn't apply to so in finance like you
can think of low dat you can think of
saving money
you can think of always having dry
powder it doesn't matter if you have the
best idea in the world if you can't take
advantage of that idea you might as well
not have the idea you have to be in a
position to take advantage of the ideas
that you have and you have to be in a
position where somebody can't sort of
like call you in at the exact wrong
moment because that's really expensive
as everybody sort of learned during the
great financial crisis and it's now
forgotten
we seem to relearn these lessons over
and over again but positioning applies
to so many other things that we don't
think about you can think about it
basically as in
your sleep right did you work out are
you healthy are you eating well are you
investing in your relationship with your
partner what position am I in and the
moment that I get into a fight or
argument or disagreement with my my
partner or my spouse and we don't think
about the position we're in at that
moment but if you imagine that there's a
patch of grass between you and them is
that grass dry or is it wet have I
watered that for months in which case
the spark isn't going to let it on fire
or is the smallest little spark gonna
start this forest fire and the position
that we bring into those arguments
matters a lot in terms of the quality of
the outcomes that we get and I'll give
you another example with we were talking
about kids earlier and I assume a lot of
people listening have kids one of my
kids came home with an exam and he got a
really terrible Mark and he hands it to
me he's like a teenager so he like hands
it to me he's like I did the best I
could walks away and normally the
conversation ends there her and I was
like okay well now is not the moment
that we're gonna talk about this because
I know that this teenage attitude thing
going on but we're going to circle back
to this and so later that night I was
like talk to me about what it means to
do the best you can and what he told me
about the best he could was like when he
sat down to write that test from 10 to
11 he focused all of his energy and all
of his effort on it he made the best
decisions possible from 10 to 11. but
what he forgot or didn't really
appreciate is what position was he in at
10 A.M when he sat down to write that
test did he fight with his brother in
the morning yep he did did he eat a
healthy breakfast nope he didn't did he
get a good night's sleep nope he was up
late did he study now he sort of
half-assed it and so what happened was
he was in a bad position at the moment
he sat down to write that test he was
ill-prepared to write the test but yes
he did the best he could in that moment
and so often we think about life in
terms of how do I do the best I can in
this particular moment rather than how
do I put myself in the best position and
part of that is like we're always
predicting we're predicting creatures
and so we're always trying to gauge what
the outcome is and maximize towards that
outcome I want to go all in on Tesla I
want to go all in on whatever because I
want to maximize my return and what we
don't think about is like okay well what
is the cost of doing that what if I'm
wrong and how do I position myself for
multiple possible Futures where what if
my idea is not correct can I still
survive and can I thrive on that and if
you look back and you sort of like look
back at Carnegie and Rockefeller and all
these you know historical people who
built these great businesses including
Buffett they always take advantage of a
weakness in somebody else's position
when their position is strong
who else would you and I know you
mentioned a few names but outside of
Buffett monger
who else would you put on your
short list and not to make you pick
favorites I'm sure that you could give a
very long list but just off the cuff if
you had to pick
five to ten people
let's just say
it could be four but you know let's aim
for five or or slightly more people who
you really respect as
incisive deliberate decision makers who
would make that list
so we have a mutual friend of all
ravacon
right you would be up there Patrick
Collison would sort of be up there cat
Cole who works at athletic greens yeah
totally one of my favorite people she's
always
one step ahead she's amazing
I think that there's very few people who
are well positioned in everything
like if you look at somebody who's
extremely good at one thing like Buffett
it comes with extreme weaknesses but you
can you can have a
a list of exemplars in your head almost
of different people who are good at
different positions but you have to pick
what what direction you're going
and then what positions do you need to
be good at to be good in that direction
and so for me like I Circle back to sort
of like core things right which people
don't really think about but they're
they're core to everything we do in
terms of like health and relationships
and friendship and purpose and Community
am I working on something that I want to
be working on but am I moving closer to
my destination and is my destination the
place I want to go and I think those
questions are stuff that we don't really
ask ourselves we're always so focused on
like how do we accomplish the outcome we
want rather than what are the key
elements to this process that allow me
to play for a long time
am I going in the right right direction
and do I want to get to where I'm going
mm-hmm
so I am going to come back to just the
the broad question of how to incorporate
thinking about cognitive biases if I'm
saying that correctly or mental and or
mental models not really I guess those
are different I'd love to have you let's
begin there how would you distinguish or
Define mental models
and then I'm going to go micro and then
we'll zoom out
so a great way to think about mental
models is the source of all bad
decisions is blind spots mental models
allow you to see a problem through a
different lens you can look at the
problem through
you can adopt a different Persona a
great example of a mental model is like
how would Tim Ferriss think about this
and then I adapt like what I know about
you and I try to see the problem from
your perspective and if I can see the
problem from your perspective now I've
I've done the one thing that actually
gets me out of cognitive biases which is
the source of all cognitive biases are
basically we believe that we're part
like the what we see is all there is and
we learned about this sort of in physics
right in grade nine I think where you're
standing on this train and you're
carrying this ball and the train is
moving at 60 miles an hour and how fast
is the ball moving well relative to you
the ball's not moving but if you're
watching the train go by the ball's
moving at 60 miles an hour and so the
source of all of our problems is that we
only see that we're this person on the
train holding this ball and we can't see
that there's a person outside who has a
completely different view into the exact
same situation that we see so we can
mentally use these tools to sort of
accommodate
how we can look into the world from a
different person's eyes or through a
different lens be that biology or
through thinking or through I mean the
most useful ones tend to be like
and then what you know just asking
yourself that simple question I
accomplished this and then what then
what happens inversion right how do I
avoid all these negative outcomes that I
don't want to get in the stoics you've
talked about this in the past the stoics
have been doing this for a long time
they call it a pre-mortem
I think that those are just really
helpful ways and what they're really
doing is they're just allowing us to put
a different lens onto the problem and
see it through a different light and by
seeing it through a Different Light we
slightly reduce our blind spots into the
problem yeah totally I've found
so the fact that I haven't read these in
decades so caveat Lector for anyone who
picks these up but some of Edward de
Bono's work I think he's originally
Maltese but some debono's two words but
or actually he may just be a
multi-citizen I can't I can't can't Peg
the nationality it doesn't really matter
he wrote a book called lateral thinking
he has another one I think it's called
the six thinking hats or something along
those lines
which similarly very helpful just for
forcing yourself as a as a portion of a
practice to look at the same situation
with a different lens a different set of
questions a different perspective
I'd love to talk to you about about
Farnam Street but more broadly
building
a business slash life slash businesses
on content on
advice on writing and to also certainly
audio but if you if you look back post
intelligence agency
on
what you have built what are some of the
more important decisions that you have
made or more important
experiments that you have run whether
they turned out as you had hoped or not
I think building a business on content
is really hard I think I never set out
to build
a media company
what I set out to do
was learn Timeless ideas from other
people and master the best of what other
people have figured out and share that
with the world as a means of giving back
and part of what I want to do in life is
leave the world a better place than I
found it and I believe in equal
opportunity and not equal outcome but
how can we have equal opportunity if we
don't share information with people and
make it accessible
so that's how I stumbled into Farnam
Street and there's been these pivotal
moments along the way and some are
intentional and some are just completely
random an example of which is
I never had email I never got people to
sign up for email until feedburner
remember when feedburner went away oh I
do I do
right so I lost like three quarters of
my audience overnight because Google
decided to shut down this thing and then
at that moment it dawned on me how can
somebody else take away my audience from
me no that's not cool how do I solve for
this problem
so I started an email list and now we
have like 600 or 700 000 people on this
the email list and I sent out an email
every Sunday basically what I'm learning
and but that was the moment I never
thought about how do I create an email
list or I need this it was like somebody
took away my Facebook has done the same
thing like Twitter to varying extents
has done the same thing they basically
take your audience away from you and
then you become platform dependent and I
don't want to be platform dependent I
don't want anybody to be between me and
the people who've chosen to read me and
get my ideas
so what are the components of your
business as it exists today and then I'm
happy to have a conversation about this
so I'm just fascinated how different
people approach things especially since
we're talking about
among other things decision making and
so on so I'd love to know how it breaks
down
currently because you've got online
courses you have the podcast you have
other things so how does the business so
to speak break down as it stands right
now
so we do a few things you remember that
diagram from Disney in the 60s and they
have like theme parks and merchandise
and how it all interconnects you can
look this up don't but I would love to
find it and we'll put in the show notes
yeah so my idea with Farnam Street was
sort of
how do I create more surface area for
people to discover Timeless content or
that they Master the best of what other
people have figured out so it's
literally not about me it's about other
people's ideas I don't really have any
original ideas I sort of
if anything maybe compress other
people's ideas in an interesting way
and so we started with a website and
then we went to a podcast and then the
podcast interesting side note here Naval
ravacon like saved the podcast because I
was like doing this podcast and I was
like nobody's listening to this podcast
and I just recorded with Naval and I was
like that's the last episode I'm gonna
do and then of course that episode goes
like parabolic it's lead to Naval right
and I was like oh my God I can't give up
on this anymore like because I wasn't at
the time I wasn't having fun doing it
now now I'm having a lot of fun doing it
then we created these series of books
called the Great mental models and the
idea behind the great mental models was
basically
what are the Big Ideas you would have
learned in University and can you apply
those outside of the context of the
domain that they were they were learned
in and so I think that that's you know
we've talked about one in terms of like
the frame of reference that you're using
to look at a problem matters a lot in
terms of what you see so we wanted to
make that accessible for people and then
we branched into a course called
decision by Design we used to have an
in-person workshop on decision making
and we learned a lot about how people
make decisions in the real world but
covid shut down all of these online
events and so we created a decision by
Design as a means to not take the same
material we were doing in person because
what we were doing in person was very
specific to being in person it was
learning from the people at your table
it was non-transferable in a way to
online so we took a more prescriptive
approach which are like one of the
things that practical tools that people
use in the real world to make decisions
and we share it with people and an
example of that is like
separating problem definition from
problem solution having two separate
meetings for that and a lot of people go
into these meetings they have one
meeting and they're like What's the
problem and then of course we work with
incredibly intelligent people and most
of them are type A and so you come in
and the first problem that statement
that sounds reasonable everybody jumps
into okay here's how we solve for that
nobody like takes a step back and it's
like wait is this problem worth solving
is this problem the real problem
because we jump into these solutions
could you give an example could be
hypothetical it could be real life of
scrutinizing the
problem statement I think this is really
important I don't do it nearly as much
as I should could you maybe walk through
what that process looks like if you if
you have an example great otherwise it
could be in the in the more abstract my
belief is that the person who makes the
decision has to come up with a problem
statement for the decision and that does
a couple things that forces the person
who's making the decision to really
understand the problem they can take
input from everybody else but ultimately
they're accountable for taking the
problem statement
and determining what that problem is and
communicating what that problem is and
also identifying which Solutions sort of
work and fit for that
when we don't do that and we just sort
of throw a problem on the table it
really backfires and so like we
trying to think of a good recent example
of this
it's a problem
well here I'll give you one of my own
so maybe we can we can Workshop that
yeah for instance I have tons of Legacy
email addresses in boxes and it is at
least at face value the story that I
tell is that it is a huge pain in the
ass and there are
different maybe security vulnerabilities
and issues with having different
platforms and things scattered all over
the place right
so the
problem in a sense has not been that
well defined it's just overall kind of
angsty hand ringing in a couple of
identified risks then we've jumped
straight into Solutions and there are
any host of different solutions that I
won't bore you with but it's it's going
to take some time
and I think I think I have a pretty good
beat on what the right direction is for
this but just for purposes of
using the the exercise how would you
scrutinize that right I come in I say
hey this is a problem we don't have
things centralized in one modern inbox
with all of the Enterprise level
security that would include therefore we
should
decommission these following inboxes and
blah blah blah right
but I'm taking for granted that that is
the right definition of the problem
right exactly so it's like who's the
check and balance on what are we solving
for and it goes back to something we
talked about earlier like what direction
am I getting closer to the destination
and is the destination the one that I
want to get to so in this case like is
the problem that you're solving I want
access to all of these materials through
one inbox or is the problem something
different which is I don't feel these
inboxes are really that secure and I
don't know how to manage them and the
way that you frame that problem will
determine in a large part what Solutions
you see is available and maybe it's
something different I mean we're just
sort of like spitballing this on the
spot here yeah totally but your surface
area is large right so all these email
addresses increase your surface area of
attack if that's your your sort of the
way that you're thinking about it and if
your goal is to reduce it one way of
reducing it might be to consolidate it
one way of reducing it might be to
eliminate them one way of reducing it
might be something completely different
yeah totally and this is timely for me
because as I was walking through
recording a screenflow for my team
related to this I realized about halfway
through because I was talking about next
actions and I said actually wait a
second My ultimate objective here is to
spend substantially less time in email
and I think
Maybe
compared to a reference point that would
be say an average of my friends I do
spend a lot less time in email but I
would like to spend more time on certain
creative projects and larger
sort of needle moving dedicated blocks
of time three to four hours for fill in
the blank project or
experiment
so it's it's not I realized pretty
quickly that if my advice were
implemented directly it would just be
taking this burden because it's not just
attack vectors it's also just lots of
unsolicited inbound right it would be
taking all of that and just moving it to
a different mailing address and I was
like okay
that sort of partially solves one issue
but it
does not at all address this separate
issue which is maybe on some level the
bigger issue even though I tend to run a
little paranoid
the unsolicited inbound is probably a
bigger problem currently than the attack
Factor stuff because I have pretty good
security as it stands
probably excessive Security in a lot of
respects
but I realized halfway through trying to
prescribe the solution I was like wait a
[__] second
I might be giving the best advice
possible for solving the wrong thing
yeah totally right and that that is in
and of itself a good reason to separate
these things but also when you're the
boss your suggestions become Direction
so you might be just thinking out loud
but like the people hearing that are
like oh Tim wants this here here's how
we solve for this and then in your head
you're like oh that sounds like a good
solution but you've solved the wrong
problem and so this is why separating
these meetings between like what is the
problem like can we get clear on what
the problem is and you don't have to go
first but like whatever your process is
it's you get the information out of
people in terms of what they see as the
problem you can take that and mull it
over and be like we'll have another
meeting tomorrow and we'll determine
Solutions or maybe next week if it's if
it's not timely and people think this
slows you down this is the biggest thing
that I hear when I talk to people about
this is they're like well that'll just
slow us down and prevent us from taking
action actually the exact opposite is
true because it increases it's sort of
like you're thinking in terms of speed
but speed doesn't have a Direction so it
doesn't matter how fast you're going if
you're running in circles you really
want to get to the best outcome possible
in the shortest amount of time with the
least amount of effort and that means
you're allowing your team to maximize
their thinking a lot of people don't
think well on the spot so having these
group meetings where everybody is
required to contribute a lot of people
mull it over they go for a walk after or
they're walking home after work that
night and then they get this idea this
spark and they're like no I don't see it
that way and then they can't contribute
at that point so you've tied one hand
behind your back in terms of maximizing
the talent on your team to solve to
figure out what the problem is and then
to solve it and so it makes a lot more
sense to be like hey we're gonna have a
30 minute meeting here and a 30 minute
meeting here instead of one 60-minute
meeting and these meetings are going to
be highly structured and we're just
going to talk about what the problem is
can we agree on what the problem is what
is everybody what do you see as the
problem what do you see into this lens
that I don't see because I I'm not you I
can't see it and that's a way also to
get out of this
I don't know people like to posture in
meetings it drives me crazy they like
basically repeat the executive summary
in their own words and like meetings go
nowhere and so a good way to avoid that
is just to assume that everybody has
read the required material and ask them
what their unique contribution to this
problem is that they don't think anybody
else sees and so now instead of
rewarding just air time now you're
rewarding unique contribution to the
problem and you get social signal out of
having a unique lens into the problem
which is much more effective that makes
perfect sense and are there other
questions that you find useful in the
problem defining sessions for instance I
mean I I can imagine
one of the questions that I would want
to ask my team
in addition to emphasizing what you just
emphasized right individual
perspective and contribution over
restating the executive summary that was
sent as as reading for the meeting to
begin with is this really a problem
right like we're assuming this is a
problem that needs to be solved but like
is this
significant enough for us to allocate
attention and resources to it compared
to other things right
I'm probably using a very clumsy wording
but what other types of are there any
other questions that you've seen be very
helpful in these
problem defining meetings
so and then what is a great question
right so if we switch to a new email
platform and then what so you can
imagine you can do a thought experiment
on what your day would look like but we
often neglect all of these other things
which is like this software doesn't do
this thing that I actually do a lot so
therefore now we have to develop a
workaround or this software is
completely different everybody has to be
trained on it or this software is not as
supported and doesn't update as much
there's all these sort of lenses but I
love the and then what question because
it's like okay if we solve this problem
what state are we in and what is the
cost in terms of time money effort brain
drain we don't think about brain drain
very often to solve this problem and the
bigger your team is the more you tend to
solve these problems that aren't really
problems because you're sort of like
creating busy work for you and I I think
we both run very small teams and so we
think through like okay if we solve this
problem then what happens how do we
develop the most leverage possible but I
think a lot of people don't tend to
think through that you know I've seen
this all the time where organizations
I've worked with have switched out
software and they switch out the
software to solve one problem and
they're ignorant to the 67 other
problems they just created by solving
that one problem and it feels good it
feels like you're doing work but at the
end of the day you're in a worse
position than you were in because you
didn't ask yourself and then what
all right so I'd love to segue for a
minute to automatic rules because for
myself at least especially running a
small team where
the default I suppose flow of things is
that a lot of decisions flow to me and I
try not to be an unnecessary bottleneck
but I have you know very small team a
few employees and automatic rules and
policies are very helpful here right so
for instance I have a blog post I put up
it's like I'm not reading any new books
this year which solves a lot of a lot of
issues as you might imagine and I have
these blanket policies for at least five
to eight years I didn't know
speaking engagements effectively I've
made a few exceptions recently but for a
long period of time I did none of that
for another I think I want to say
probably three to four years No Angel
Investing right and and these were rules
that prevented decision fatigue and just
allowed me a lot more
cognitive bandwidth and emotional and
physical bandwidth so what are some of
your automatic roles I've got a few here
work out every day no days off invest in
an index fund every month no meetings
before 12. do you want to spend maybe a
few minutes on those and then any other
examples that come to mind so before I
get into a few more examples like let's
back up for a second mm-hmm automatic
rules turn your desired Behavior into
your default behavior and they do it
when you're at your best and so you can
pre-decide a lot of things and why are
rules effective instead of just a
pre-decision you need it to be a rule
and the word rule is very specific and
very useful
and I got this idea from Daniel conman
and we were talking and he said
I have a rule I never say yes on the
phone
he was explaining why he had just told
somebody that he'd tell them he'd talk
to them again tomorrow and follow up
with them and they had asked him to do
something and I was like that's really
interesting why why do you have that
rule and he said that rule is so that I
don't end up saying yes because I feel
social pressure to say yes to these
things and I want to please other people
like all of us want to please other
people and he's like I learned over
years and this this is like fascinating
will blow your mind will change your
life he's like I learned over years
people don't argue with rules
and I follow them so we're taught our
whole life to follow rules but we've
never thought of like how can we create
rules for ourselves that we just follow
when we're at our worst when we're sort
of like in the worst situation possible
we all know no matter how bad our day is
we shouldn't speed on the highway
because it's against the rules
what we don't think about is
how do we use rules to our advantage
a great example I had a friend who who
basically lost a whole bunch of weight
using this Rule and he basically said
every time I go out for dinner and he
ate out for dinner a lot in his life for
work he's like I ordered my rule is I
order the healthiest thing on the menu
and I don't drink
meaning no alcohol meaning no alcohol
right so
and he didn't order dessert that was his
sort of like third Rule and if you think
about dessert dessert's an interesting
one because I think we can all relate to
it you go out you celebrate with your
friends the wine comes out the champagne
comes out the dessert comes out and all
of a sudden you're doing things that may
be the best version of you doesn't want
to do but you're in a social situation
you feel pressure you can tell people
I'm not eating dessert you know I don't
want dessert tonight but that relies on
Willpower so every time you say I don't
want dessert tonight you're you're using
willpower to get out of that situation
and eventually everybody loses the
battle with willpower so how can you
create a system to get out of this
willpower thing where it's like I'm not
using willpower I create an automatic
rule I don't eat dessert that's my rule
and when you say that to your friends
you might have to say it twice but they
definitely push back a lot less as long
as you're consistent with that rule but
that rule puts you in the best position
possible for success and so like I have
a couple of these rules right when I
when I'm out after after a talk with the
people who organized the talk my rule is
I stopped drinking at nine nothing good
happens after nine and so like you just
choose in advance and a great way to
think about this again is going back to
what we talked about earlier Direction
destination what does a person who
achieves this destination what do they
behave like can I create automatic rules
in my life and they're so context
specific they're so specific to you
because they're also things you don't do
naturally like I I hate working out
right but I want to be healthy it's
really important to me to be healthy and
I was struggling and this is where the
workout everyday rule came in I was
struggling to go three times a week
because I would get into this
negotiation with myself and that
negotiation was like you know I normally
work out on Wednesdays but that little
voice in my head is like you didn't
sleep well last night you have a lot of
work on your plate and then all of a
sudden I'm like I'll do extra tomorrow
I'll catch myself doing saying you know
this sort of talk and I'm why am I
negotiating with myself like who's in
charge here I'm in charge of this
situation and so I I changed it I'm like
I'm gonna work it every day and it
doesn't mean I go to the gym every day
and it doesn't mean I go for 60 minutes
I can reduce the the scope or sort of
like duration of my workout but I'm
going to work out every single day and
that workout might be a five mile walk
it might be something else it doesn't
matter but there's going to be some form
of exercise involved and that single
rule has changed so many people's lives
that I've shared it with because you
start exercising every day because the
negotiation in your head now is like
what do I fit in today how can I fit
this in it's not should I work out it's
like oh I don't have a lot of time maybe
I'll just do 20 minutes maybe I'll just
go to the gym and do squats and all of a
sudden you get in this habit you're
consistently working out so your health
starts to get a lot better it's
mind-blowing how this simple principle
can have profound impact do you have any
rules for yourself so many I want to
hear some of yours yeah well I will say
that as you're talking you know my my
father for instance has in the last it's
been very fast actually maybe in the
last two to three months has lost 50
pounds
and he's done that by following the Slow
Carb Diet in
the four-hour body or as described by
the for our body people can find it
online certainly without having to buy
any book but the key there one of the
keys is having a very straightforward
Rule and the rule is you don't have to
give up your favorite foods the rest of
your life you just have to give up your
favorite foods for six days at a time
and you have a set cheat day every week
and that also allows you to get off the
hook or to successfully negotiate with
yourself with your friends because you
say
it's my policy that I only have cheat
day once a week on Saturday so if you
want to have dessert booze whatever it
might be not in my dad's case with with
those two but I'm happy to do it but
it's got to be on a Saturday right and
then all of a sudden the negotiation is
over there is no negotiation yeah so I
would say when I am my best self which I
am right now
let's see another rule would be if I
want to follow the Slow Carb Diet have
pre-made meals ready to go in the
refrigerator for at least three to four
days at a time so I did that today for
instance because if I start to run out
of food and I'm picking at the dregs of
whatever I have sitting around and I'm
starting to starve but lo and behold I
have a podcast to do I'm going to go buy
something fast that is not going to
conform to the diet so batch processing
buying
or having bought food so that it's ready
to go I mean I have a lot of policies so
as it relates to inbound and I have an
autoresponder that kicks back a lot of
this stuff I'll tell you some of the
rules that have existed for a while
generally speaking no speaking
engagements and I could explain why that
is that was a particularly hard one when
I made the decision because speaking
engagements for authors who have
best-selling books is very lucrative and
it is in fact the main source of income
for a lot of authors yes and I just
realized categorically I had to say no
because moderation it was very hard to
moderate my commitments with speaking
engagements yeah and it's addictive
right like it is on a plane you get this
big check and then you could do it all
over again
and then you end up booking your life
out nine months in advance and it crowds
out a lot of other things so like the
metaphor of the sort of apocryphal story
of the professor asks his students to
fit the two rocks and a handful of
Pebbles and then the sand into the jar
and the lesson is you got to put in the
big rocks first and then the Pebbles and
then the sand but you can't do it the
other way around you can't do it in any
other order where the big rocks won't
fit and I realized for myself that was
true of speaking engagements what I did
do as an interim for that is when I
would say yes to speak engagements
I would do I had a complete barbell
approach so I'd either do free so it had
to be so incredibly compelling maybe
that's because it's cause based and I
really aligned with a very narrow band
of things that I commit myself to on
that side
or it had to be a paid gig matching or
above my previous high water mark so
whatever the highest amount that I had
been paid was it had to match or exceed
that never below and that automatically
constrained the volume of things that I
could commit to and made it manageable
and by the way the people who are
willing to do that were always the
easiest to deal with you would think
maybe intuitively that the people who
pay the most would be the most demanding
and the most difficult that has not been
my experience at all it's actually
completely the opposite
and
I have many other rules so the no new
books would be another one if anyone
tries to rush me into a decision via
email or on the phone the answer is no
it's not just that I postpone giving an
answer the answer is no if I feel like
someone is rushing me into a decision
the answer is no if someone's rushing me
because reading between the lines they
don't want me to have enough time for
proper legal review a lot of startups do
this it's very annoying where they'll
send you docs on like Friday afternoon
and say well we need to close this round
and like we we need to get signatures
back by
10 a.m on Monday and I'm like then it's
a [__] no I'm sorry I'm an adult and
I don't play these games
so there are a handful of things like
that I'll give you another one for the
podcast and I'm going to ask you a
similar question for the the business
side of things for you and the creative
side but I'd love to hear any so for
instance for the podcast everything is
prepaid all invoices are prepaid and
that is something that very few podcasts
can do it's it's something that very few
podcasts
I think can manage given the business
Norms generally it's net 30 or net 60 or
some type of net payment terms but to
manage that you either need to have a
reasonably large team you need to have
someone fully dedicated to chasing down
payment or you need to work with outside
agencies to pick up that burden I didn't
want to deal with any of that and so I
said look this is I recognize a
trade-off and with these rules I think
you would probably agree there are
trade-offs there are always going to be
trade-offs but if decision is like
decision kind of like incision like The
Cutting away that's fine so you're
cutting away certain possible outcomes
but if I make a rule that everyone has
to prepay
a few things happen number one the
universe of possible sponsors we need to
consider goes down dramatically secondly
the people who are willing to do that
again counter-intuitively are generally
people who are measuring twice cutting
once and are going to be the easiest to
deal with later yeah we don't always bat
a thousand but we do pretty well so
those would be some of the rules I've
got all sorts of other ones dude as you
were saying that there's a couple things
that came to mind one is I can often
determine from an initial Outreach of an
investment whether I want to do the deal
before I even know the specifics because
it's like how fair is this to me and if
the deal is like one-sided towards you
like an example of which is like hey I
need this by uh you can't get it legally
reviewed or you have to get your lawyers
working overtime I need it by Monday
well I don't want to be a partner with
that person no that's the honeymoon
phase should be easier so that's an easy
no but like often like when we're
investing in a lot of private businesses
that aren't necessarily startups that
are profitable businesses I can tell by
the valuation the pitch like what people
are looking for what their optimal
scenario is if I want to be a partner
with that because if you're presenting a
deal that isn't fair to me right now
you're never going to be fair to me in
the future so it has to be win-win and
people don't understand like there's
literally four permutations of a
relationship there's win-win win lose
lose win and lose lose and only one of
those permutations can survive time and
what do we want with time we want to
compound relationships you want to
invest in companies where you don't have
to review the legal documents because
you you trust the people involved you've
worked with them before they're
consistent they show up they do what
they say they're going to do and maybe
the investment doesn't work out but
that's not what you're thinking about
you're not worried about them stabbing
you in the back and so so often we do
things that just take us off this
compounding train and and I think it was
Naval who said you know one of the big
lessons from compounding is that all the
gains come at the end they don't come at
the start and so you have to stay you
have to stay on this timeline so every
relationship has to be win-win and for
like the podcast we do like no paid
speaking which is it's so interesting
I'm sure you get these pitches too it's
like here I'll give you 100 Grand to
come on your show I'll pay in advance
yada yada and then I always look up
these people and I'm like oh now I know
the podcasts that like accept money for
guest speakers but we do the same thing
with this prepaid stuff and this came
back to about us because I'm a high
trust person I operate on trust I don't
want to be in business with you if we
need a contract I mean that's generally
my motto it doesn't mean we don't have
contracts but it means if I feel the
need of a contract it's in easy no for
me yeah if you need a contract to
protect you from someone you don't
really trust your plan uh you're playing
a gambler's game but often you
you don't trust them but you'll think of
the contract and then you'll need a
contract and that's the first indication
that something's amiss in this
relationship and so we've never used
advertising contracts
but during coved this came back to bite
us because we would invoice a lot of our
advertisers once a year and we invoiced
them on March 31st
after we have delivered all of their
advertising for the past year and we've
worked with people for years and then
all of a sudden we're delivering these
invoices March 31st 2020 and people are
like we're not paying that I'm like whoa
what do you mean we're not paying this
like that doesn't make any sense we've
worked together for four years how is
this even possible
am I missing something and they're like
basically sue me and I'm like oh [__]
what what is going on here this is crazy
interestingly enough a few of them have
come back and tried to advertise with us
they're like we'll pay our old invoice
and I'm like you should pay that and
then we'll talk but like there's no way
I'm gonna like sign up to work with you
again yeah no thanks and the speaking
thing again that comes back to like
where do I want to get to in life I do
the exact same thing except I sort of
limited I'm like here's the number of
speaking engagements I can do this year
it's like six or ten depending on the
year depending on on sort of like what I
want to do that year and then we use
price as a function to modulate that in
the sense of I love your high Watermark
idea I think that's really important and
that's a great way that I had never
thought about doing it and I just use
hey I only do six a year here's the cost
and it just eliminates most people and
to your point the people that say yes
are the easiest freaking people to deal
with in the world and they want you
there and there's no like 16 hours of
pre-calls and like all of this other
stuff now they've decided they want you
as a speaker you're not one of ten they
will gladly accept that's when you get
into all sorts of comms overload and
brain damage yeah that I don't want to
deal with so if you had to double down
on one or two things you are already
doing what would you double down on oh
definitely the email list I think that
that is is the key right if you can pick
one primary focus for this you need to
be able to reach your audience you need
to be able to communicate with them and
however you do that whether you do it
building it through Twitter or Instagram
you want sort of all past to lead back
to your email list and the person who
does this the best is James Clear
there's a machine he's a machine right
like Instagram points back to his
website Facebook points back to his
website Twitter you know he's just
really really smart at this so if you're
gonna model yourself off somebody and
you want to build an email list like
he's the person to sort of like think
about you also have a huge audience for
email
I do yes I'm very very grateful very
methodical too I mean I've thought about
it although like you didn't think about
it at all until a few things happened
including feed burner sending a
notification we are about to turn off
everything yeah and then began emailing
however long ago it was
which has been a great actually a really
fun process for me because five bullet
Friday serves as my diary effectively
yes I don't have a separate diary so
it's fun to look back you know two years
ago it's like there's one that comes out
every week and I can look back two years
and go oh yeah I remember an exact week
locked in the Amber like some
prehistoric you know mosquito or
something yeah and I can revisit and you
also realize how like stupid you were or
at least I do when I look back at some
of my old newsletters I was like oh what
was I think but that's also a really
positive sign because you're growing but
but going back to the question you know
I would focus on email and I would ditch
podcasts at this point and just double
down on email and long form content
counter-intuitively on the web
let's just say I was like
wish granted boom poof podcast just
dissolves into The Ether with a rainbow
and you know some winning of unicorns
and it's all wonderful but that that has
come to a close and then you're doubling
down on email and
what was the phrasing that you just used
but it was sort of online long-form
content content how would you do that
like what might things look like in the
next three months if you were doubling
down on on those things just for context
like I was operating under the guise of
starting from scratch so okay we got it
pick a vector and that Vector would be
sort of creating content that people
find useful and Timeless and it's super
important the word Timeless is really
important there because you want that
you want the compounding effect you want
the cumulative effect to work to your
advantage so if you're creating content
that is easily consumed but no longer
relevant in a week a month even a year
then that content can't work for you
when you're not working yeah but a lot
of the stuff that you do on your blog
and definitely the stuff that we do on
fs.blog is it's always relevant it's
Evergreen you've re like that we just
re-aired that interview with Naval
ravacon we recorded it six years ago
people thought it was recorded yesterday
we don't talk politics you know we avoid
these certain subjects so I think what I
would do is like I would focus on
creating the best content I could I
would get people who come to the website
to give me their email address and I
would think about not expanding that
surface area like just creating better
how do I write the next article how do I
make it useful and then spending a lot
of time thinking about how do I share
that where do people who who are like me
who will find this interesting where do
they hang out how can I let them know
about it but I wouldn't go in what
people tend to do is the two mistakes I
see in I guess if people are trying to
do sort of like what we've done or we're
doing
is they spread themselves too thin so
they're like oh I'm gonna start a blog
I'm gonna create a podcast I'm gonna
just do an email newsletter and it's
like man you have no idea how much work
all that stuff is like good luck uh and
the other thing that I see a lot of
people doing is just sort of like
thinking it's gonna be easy and so they
they get into this trap of like oh I
said something that's really popular a
wrote an article is really popular and
now I'm going to write another one on
the same thing and another one on the
same thing and sort of like by the end
of the year it's like you're just
posting the same stuff and whether
that's sort of like
aggressive sort of like tweets or
something like you just become something
you wouldn't read and so I don't look at
stats on the website I look at the email
stats sort of like once a week but I
never look at like what's the most
popular article because I never want
that to guide the next article I just
really want to follow what I'm
interested in what I'm curious about
where my energy is and I feel like that
a cohort of people will find that and be
like Oh I found my tribe like this is my
person I'm so glad there's somebody else
interested in this other than me and
that's sort of like how I think about
building it but you have to find that
thing for you and I think it's really
really critical that you don't spread
yourself too thin and try to do
everything and then you you can sort of
like create these systems in your life
that allow you to do that which is let's
say you want to do that and you want to
work full time at the same time but you
want to you want to slowly build up this
body of content that works for you while
you're working well one way to do that
is write every morning from five until
six
and so you just block off the best hour
of your day for right most people do it
the other way they block off the worst
hour of their day which might be at
night and so they come home after all
this baggage and all this work and then
they spend all their time and effort
sort of like trying to focus instead of
like actually just letting it flow and
and writing yeah I mean as far as rules
go right I mean the Evergreen slash
Timeless piece has always been
important to me for all the reasons that
you're mentioning including the energy
giving because
if we were to to look at it from a
different perspective if you are
competing for attention and I don't want
to make it seem zero-sum but if you are
trying to draw people to what you are
producing in some capacity if you choose
timely news driven
topics or people or stuff that's getting
sensationalized or stuff that's really
controversial and polarizing
you are stepping into the bloodiest most
crowded Arena imaginable
Timeless stuff or the Evergreen stuff is
hard to do you're also capping I think a
lot of your growth frankly but
that's okay well you you grow slower but
you increase the timeline you have for
growth right like the runway becomes
longer even if you're growing slower in
the short term exactly you have
compounding gains in the form of
audience growth and so on that will be
more sustained as opposed to fair
weather readers or listeners who are
just chasing whatever the algorithm
serves them on any given day in any
given minute so question just on the
compounding thing because if Naval of
course is an incredible investor I'd
love to know
a bit about how you personally think
about investing because it seems like
you do some private deals also seems
like you invest in an index fund or
index funds
could you say more about that could you
also speak to whether or not you think
investing in in disease I guess it is
has substantially changed now that as I
understand it big Tech
factors vary heavily into at least some
of the the indices or indexes I'm not
sure which the the proper word is to use
here but how do you how do you
personally think about investing
I use the cash flows from Farnam Street
to invest and one of the advantages to
being you or me that a lot of people
don't have is deal flow so you get deal
flow that the best VCS in the world
would be envious of
and to some extent so do I and so you've
created this vehicle that wasn't
primarily for investing but has this big
benefit to it where you're able to get
deal flow because of all the other
things you do not because you're focused
on Deal flow every day and so I wanted
to use that to my advantage in terms of
how do we get into good deals how do I
create something sustainable how do I
create something long term and how do I
apply this knowledge that I'm having fun
applying right like I I like investing I
don't do a ton of VC investing I I try
to invest mostly in terms of check size
it's almost all allocated to
companies that are making money or
something that I really understand the
path of I occasionally invest with
friends but I when I invest with friends
my rule is go back to rules I write that
investment off to zero the minute I
write the check because I never want my
investment with friends to affect our
friendship so in my head it's just a
zero the minute the check comes out it's
a donation yeah it's a donation to them
and I'd rather be wrong supporting a
friend than right not supporting them
like it doesn't that doesn't do anything
for our friendship and so I think about
like the things that I understand and
then diversifying because I'm not I
don't use outside money there's no
outside investors there's Shane and so I
think about like how do I survive not
not how do I maximize my returns in the
short term how do I maximize my returns
in the long term rule number one for
Warren Buffett don't lose money rule
number two is like see rule number one
so I want to diversify when it makes
sense but I also want to be in a
position where I can float to whatever
makes sense like I don't you know we we
have a real estate company where we
invest in real estate but we'll wait
until there's a lot of distress until we
put more money into that and then I can
be patient I can go years without making
an investment is that mostly residential
commercial what kind of stuff all
residential all residential yeah so it's
multi-family like multi-filmy at scale
and so like I just want to do things
where there's a long Runway I'm working
with people I trust the financial
returns are sort of like justifying the
investment but also the advantage to
being you or I or this one person sort
of team is you can put yourself in a
position where you don't have to like
you said you stop VC investing for years
you don't have to make an investment
nobody's emailing you going Tim why
haven't you made an investment nobody's
emailing you going what are you doing
with my money all of a sudden you can
just let cash pile up on the balance
sheet right like you can just let it
accumulate in the bank account and then
when you see an opportunity where their
risks and rewards sort of indicate that
this is favorable and you have an edge
in this particular investment then you
can write a large check in like 12 hours
like there's no investment committee to
go through there's nothing to do it's
just you making a decision and so I I
like that aspect of it and I think about
it that way I do the index fund thing
it's sort of outside all of that
which is just like I like fail safes I
don't know about you but like I hide
money from myself at times so like the
real estate company when I log into my
bank it doesn't even show up on the list
of companies we have it's just like this
separate entity that I I log into once a
year to get the financial statements for
the accountants but mentally I've
convinced myself it doesn't exist which
I think is like a really powerful way
for me because
I don't want to convince myself that I'm
smarter than I am at any of this stuff
and I also always want to think that I'm
in a worse position than I am because I
really want to increase and improve my
position
and has your thinking on indexing
investing changed over the years or is
it like I like I see oftentimes you know
people saying it's not timing the market
it's time in the market so just keep
buying right just keep buying with
respect to
an index or any any number of different
index funds how is your thinking remain
the same or changed with respect to
index investing the weighting of the top
companies has definitely caused me a
little bit of hesitation
what what I do with indexing is while I
invest in an index fund every month I
don't always invest the same amount of
money in the index fund so when if you
want to think of this sort of very
simplistically when there's panic and
nobody wants to invest I tend to put
more money in and when everybody's
investing and we're reaching all-time
highs I tend to put Less in I don't know
if that's an effective strategy for
everybody else it's just sort of what I
do to regulate money going into index
funds but what we haven't seen with
index funds that worries me is with the
rise of index funds we haven't seen
massive Force selling of index funds and
how that impacts the funds and so I'm
actually sort of counter-intuitively
thinking you know the rise of activists
investors they just went through this
10-year spell where they didn't
outperform and they're really smart I'm
kind of thinking like now might be the
time to allocate more money into that
pocket
because I think that you know there
there might be an opportunity when index
funds are no longer sort of what we're
thinking of as index funds and they
always go up and all of a sudden stock
picking comes back in Vogue and you can
buy some of them like you can buy
perishing square at like I don't know I
don't know what today's price is but
like a 30 discount to its net asset
value and I remember doing this during
covid so March 2020 Bill Ackman got on
TV and he's like I have these like
asymmetric bets and I was like oh Bill's
a really smart guy I know him so I
started looking at the net asset value
of parachute square and it's like the
Market's tanking at the same time the
net asset value is like going parabolic
so I was just buying all the shares I
could and that's all publicly available
information but you have to be in a
position to take advantage of that
information with cash otherwise you're
you're for selling something to do it
how do you think about Index Fund
investor what do you do with your money
oh my God I'm in the process of
tremendously
I don't want to say de-risking because I
I that would presume that I accurately
can identify and understand all the
various risks out there which is kind of
ridiculous would be a ridiculous thing
for me to claim but I I have realized
that many many many of my investments
are highly correlated and I've always
been growth first and I have friends I'm
not going to name names but friends were
like look there is no role for Bonds in
your portfolio you don't need the cash
like you should be a hundred percent go
go and these are very smart people who
have done very very well over long
periods of time and intellectually
let's first of all say I'm not a
financial advisor I do not recommend
anyone take that advice but this is this
is advice that a few of my friends were
giving to me based on their
understanding of my life and what I came
to realize is that
while
academically that might be true
it actually makes it harder for me to
sleep so I am making a number of
decisions right now that for anyone who
is type A super driven successful
growth-minded investor would look at a
scance and consider probably pretty
stupid but for me I'm realizing number
one
I don't need to Chase
I don't need to chase extra gains
necessarily I mean I I have areas where
I feel like I have informational
Advantage with early stage stuff if if I
decided two years from now I want double
triple down or 10x down on that sector I
could do that pretty easily
so I'm going to try and experiment for a
few years I'm in the process of doing
this right now where I'm going to be
moving a lot of my cash from sort of
growth positions I can't do that in all
cases because a lot of my stuff is
locked up in private but I'll be moving
a lot from areas that are high growth
but that are high complexity and
difficult for me to understand that
applies to a bunch of stuff overseas
where I don't think
the world is as siled as it once was I
mean Nasim taleb and I were talking
about this recently where you know the
idea that you're protected from the ups
and downs of say the US by being in
Western Europe is kind of ridiculous and
that's true even further afield so
I'm trying to I suppose at this point
optimize for sleep that's it and I I'm
sure I'm going to look back a few years
from now and say [__] man the
opportunity cost was so high but there
are periods of time where I've been red
hot and I've been able to strike
most notably when I had much less cash
in sort of 2008 to 2012 let's say which
was a an incredible vintage and uh
period for startup investing if someone
were to give me my starting Capital that
I had then now even adjusted for
inflation say go get them tiger I would
not succeed I really don't think I would
be able to do what I did then the world
has just changed the evaluations and the
deal structuring all of these things
have changed
however
there have been these these Pockets
where I've been able to make good
decisions only because I have extra
powder and right now I feel like I'm or
at least over the last handful of years
pretty fully deployed where I could get
in a position if I screw up my planning
where I'm a forced seller or at least a
distress seller right not not in any
kind of bet the farm way but it adds
stress and I think that after so long
and
really focusing so hard and in for
periods of time working so hard to get
to a point where I don't need to
fortunately and there's a lot of luck
involved but worry about my expenses
like to manufacture a complicated
strategies for life that add that stress
back in is kind of ridiculous it's
completely absurd
so I'm trying not to do that and I
notice among my friends like almost all
of them do this and we laugh about it
it's like oh yeah I managed to remove
this stress let me figure out a really
sophisticated like self
sabotaging subconscious way to add all
that stress right back in
so there's a long answer to a short
question but well it's so interesting
because you hit on a couple things there
that really resonate with me and how I
approach things the first was you you
were like the opportunity cost is huge
well no because you're only considering
the measurable opportunity cost you
can't measure your sleep at night as
easily right right and so that decision
makes perfect sense like why risk what
you have and don't need for like what
you don't have and don't want to begin
with yeah right it doesn't make sense to
take those risks at a certain when
you're young it makes sense to take a
lot of risk in order to sort of get
ahead but as you get older and you have
more to lose sure you can keep pushing
that button as long as you want but at
some point it doesn't always have to be
a pure financial decision an example of
that is when I when I left sort of
working for the intelligence agency I
had this amazing pension and they're
like well starting at 55 we're going to
pay you this much money every year and
it's a pretty big sum of money like I
worked a lot of years there and get a
really decent salary and I was like no
cash it in and my accountant was like
what do you mean cash it in like that is
the worst financial decision you can
make and I'm like it's the worst
financial decision but it's the best
psychological decision because if I know
somebody's coming to save me I'm gonna
behave differently I need all the chips
on the table in front of me and I need
to know it's on me and I know that
doesn't make sense to you but for me
that's the only way that I'm gonna have
a shot at being successful at this
Also may not to State the obvious but
let's go for it
past
shelter food all the basics and then a
couple of extracurricular fun things
here and there beyond that
even for that the extracurriculars I
mean presumably the money is used to
improve your quality of life so if
you're doing things to make money that
are decreasing your quality of life
it's sort of antithetical to the whole
name of the game in in some respect 100
which I'm saying in part to remind
myself of it because I'm making a lot of
decisions right now which for me
provoke a visceral
angst because I have been so
during periods I've made some terrible
decisions too let's be very clear I've
made some very terrible very expensive
decisions but there have been these
Sprints of say four or five years where
I've made
a series of very good decisions that
tend to be opportunistic
the podcast is a great example yeah that
was nowhere in a three five or ten year
plan
it's very opportunistic and the timing
was really fortunate
and
therefore when i s when I start moving
as I am right now quite a bit into let's
just call it safer stuff that's Up For
Debate but let's just call it safer
stuff
it's very counter to my
conditioned way of being in the world
you know what I mean so it's an
experiment I'm also viewing it like look
yeah I'm gonna pay a bunch of hits here
and there and I'm blah blah blah tax
this tax that let's not let that Tail
Wag the Dog if we can avoid it but I'm
gonna do it for let's just call it two
years and see how I feel right if I'm
happy I did it great and if I'm sleeping
better great and if I'm like okay that
was an interesting experiment but
actually I want to get back in The Fray
and roll up my sleeves and like really
go at it in this full contact sport
known as all this early stage stuff
you know then fine it's not a permanent
decision I think that's an interesting
way to think about it I mean you could
also like if you feel the need to keep
going you've accomplished so much and
you've done really well you could also
just put money aside enough money aside
that if everything else went to zero
you'd be okay hide that bank account
from yourself basically invest it in in
you know sort of like safe reliable
stuff and then pretend it doesn't exist
and then and then go nuts right and then
like with all the other stuff you can
sort of like play these little mind
games on yourself where it's like oh you
know all of a sudden I'm worthless I
gotta make more right and if that's your
goal is to do that but I'm totally with
you and like money should improve the
quality of life that you're living and a
lot of things that that looks like it's
counterintuitive to most people because
it looks like time it looks like you're
buying time
I know we were winding to close shortly
but I want to ask you
perhaps just broad Strokes
how should people think about becoming
better at making decisions and here's
the the backdrop for that you know in
the room next door I have poor Charlie's
Almanac yeah I love reading about mental
models
however I sometimes run into this
cognitive indigestion when I try to
force feed myself too many rules
cognitive biases fill in the blank I get
to a point where I fail from too much
information not too little information
just like if a friend of mine and this
has happened a lot who has no exercise
habit no controlled diet to speak of
comes to me and says hey give me an
index card with like the 20 things I
should do to get whatever six-pack abs
by
the end of the year it never works it
works exactly zero percent of the time
and I have found that sometimes I try to
take on too much at once sometimes I
find looking at decisions retroactively
to be helpful but I'm not sure there are
people who would say well we don't
actually learn that much from our
failures I think Peter Thiel would
probably underscore that
how would you suggest people go about
getting better
at making decisions what are some of the
approaches or tools in the toolkit I
think we hit on
a couple things during this episode and
I'll tie this in in a second so
most of the time when we know we're
making a decision we tend to do fairly
well in that moment given the
information we have because we're
rational about the sense that like we're
mostly rational we don't get it perfect
but we're directionally correct if
you're thinking about marrying your
partner you know you're making a
decision if you're thinking about buying
a house you know you're making a
decision in those moments we tend to be
more rational you know we might be wrong
in the end but we're not really wrong
especially given the information we have
at the time or generally correct so when
it comes back to General decision making
like here's how you undo yourself you
can marry the best person in the world
for you but if you don't invest in that
relationship it all multiplies by zero
and investing in that relationship
becomes not a decision right like
because you're not thinking about it as
a decision you start living with
somebody and then all of a sudden you
know you're arguing over how you loaded
the dishwasher and you know it turns
into not talking to each other well if I
tap you on the shoulder in that moment
and I say hey okay Tim you're about to
put gas or water onto this situation
what are you what would you like to
choose and that's what I do with my kids
and they're always like oh water but
what I'm really doing is like hey you're
making a decision to escalate here is
that the decision you want to be making
no judgment on my part but like I'm just
going to alert you to the fact you're
making a decision and that tends to help
a lot in terms of making better
decisions so how are the the moments
that happen in everyday life how do we
recognize their decisions and I would
say the biggest Aid to judgment in
decision making is the position you're
in at the time you're making a decision
it comes back to a lot of what we talked
about today there's three sort of
aspects to decision making that I think
about that are very counter-intuitive
which is the position you're in at the
time you make the decision
can you manage your emotions not
eliminate them manage them your
temperament right you don't want to be
making a decision when you're hungry
angry lonely tired you don't want to be
making a decision when you're focused on
proving yourself right rather than
getting the best outcome I have this
phrase I remind myself with which is
outcome over ego am I focused on getting
the best outcome or am I focus on
satisfying myself improving myself right
because the minute I'm proving myself
right what tends to happen is I ignore
all this information that says that I'm
not right and then all of a sudden I'm
not focused on the outcome so by
reminding yourself to focus on the
outcome you sort of like open your idea
and you get this when you run a business
it tends to be a little easier in some
ways because you're you're so tied and
wed to this outcome that you're looking
for ideas no matter where they come from
you're looking for the best idea to get
you to the outcome you want and the
third aspect is sort of thinking
independently are you thinking
independent of the circumstances or the
circumstances thinking for you are you
thinking independently of what the crowd
is doing or is the crowd thinking for
you because if those are happening if
circumstances or the crowd are thinking
for you you're not really thinking at
all but what do you have to do to think
independently you have to be well
positioned so that you can think
independently all right one last
question before we
land the plan and that is
if it's possible what is the short
explanation for why we should write in
the age of AI
writing is the process by which we
realize we don't understand what we're
talking about
and it's only when you sit down and put
pen to paper or even type
out an idea that you have a decision
you're making an idea you're wrestling
with that you sort of see where you
don't understand it and the process of
writing is not only
refining that idea and helping you
reflect on it but you actually generate
new ideas in the process of writing and
I think it's so easy my kids do this
right they're just like oh insert these
little variables into chat GPT out comes
an essay and I'm like you can't use that
you can you can feed it your essay and
ask it like where the weak points are
that's a different way of using it than
sort of like getting it to write these
essays for you but you know the question
they have is like why would I write like
this doesn't make sense you know this
thing will do it for me and I'll get a
good grade and the other aspect I would
say that's important to writing is you
learn humility right like you learn to
give up on an idea that you have like
you keep trying to fit this idea in and
you've probably experienced this too and
you you really want this idea to work
maybe you have a great opening sentence
to a paragraph but like it just doesn't
make sense and you can't make it make
sense so you have to give up on it you
have to delete it you literally have to
delete something from your mind and be
like no that doesn't make sense no
that's not good enough and I feel like
there's a certain humility due to that
that we're almost lacking in today
yeah you're not going to be able to
examine your own thinking if the source
material is produced by chat GPT yeah
what you're really doing is like you
have all these thoughts right and you're
making the invisible visible and by
making the invisible visible now I can
see it now I can play with it now I can
see where it's weak and where it's
strong and how it interacts with other
ideas I have but when it's just in your
head then you can't see it so you can't
reason with it you can't play with it
you just end up playing these mental
games with yourself where you trick
yourself into thinking something that
you don't actually think yeah I mean and
I'm bullish on so many
facets of of AI so I'm not a Luddite
who's trying to keep the the horse and
buggy at its Pinnacle or anything like
that however I do think there's a risk
of us
subjugating our own faculties in the
same way that most of us have lost the
ability to navigate without Google Maps
or some equivalent if you remove your
long form thinking and remove the habit
of putting that down in some forms such
that you can
cross-examine it and identify where
you're just not making any sense or
maybe there's a shred of something that
comes out spontaneously that makes a
whole lot of sense but if you hadn't
captured it you would never would have
noticed it as it passed through your
mind
I can't help but think that you will be
incredibly weakened over time and if
we're either getting stronger or weaker
I'd say directionally we want to go
towards the former when possible
definitely one of the crazy things is
like writing is often the process by
which we learn to think
yeah for sure yeah you're not writing
down what you think you're writing in
order to think right
I was just journaling this morning in
fact and
one of my one of my lines which was
borrowed from some of my friends in the
military super simple I mean this is not
a incredibly granular rule but just as a
guiding philosophy slow is smooth and
smooth is fast do not [__] Rush In
other words like when I rush I make
mistakes those mistakes cost me more
time in the long run just like trying to
make decisions quickly before defining
the problem correctly it's like you want
to be if you want to be fast in the long
term it's like for me at least slow is
smooth and smooth as fast uh Shane the
new book is yeah it's a good one clear
thinking turning ordinary moments into
extraordinary results people can find
that wherever find books are sold and
people can find the Farnam Street
website at fs.blog if I'm not mistaken
anything else that you would like to
mention
anything you would like to add maybe
recommendations or requests of the
audience
before we come to a close
if you want to email me at Shane at
fs.blog I read everything but I don't
respond to everything I would love to
know about sort of the ideas from this
episode that connect to ideas that you
have in terms of decision making and
positioning and what your best ideas are
for how you position yourself to sort of
survive in different environments and
adapt to whatever the situation requires
and dig it all right folks you got it
God be with you Shannon your inbox Shane
it at this top Vlog and it was really
nice to spend some time together Shane
thank you for blocking it out and making
the time to get together really
appreciate it this was awesome looking
forward to getting together in person
soon yeah definitely and for people
listening as always thank you for tuning
in you can find the show notes including
the Disney diagram will hunt down and
everything else we referred to at
tim.blog podcast and until next time
just be a bit Kinder than is necessary
not only to others but to yourself and
thanks for tuning in